is this blindness of the white Rook can
just step forward one square and capture
a black pawn
and he has and Magnus look at him oh my
words just hallucination he forgot this
Pawn was up for grabs could it be a
mouse lip could he have intended to play
the queen look at shakaya trying to look
around the computer to see what's going
on I don't think it's a mouse slick
because he he as soon as he only went
Shaq took the pawn did he react we can
jump forward to give a check and that's
what's happened because he just lost his
Pawn yeah he just leaned back and put
his hand on his head on he just lost a
pawn for free suddenly no more easy win
this is a fight how he just gave away a
pawn for free it's a rare to achieve
such a kind of dynamic kind of
bulletproof opening repertoire but he
has that and Magnus starting in
provocative fashion he's gone for the
modern defense and uh we've seen him
employ this before yesterday uh with
success Magnus Carlsen Prague has
clearly come prepared why it's H Pawn
watching forward Simon you must be
loving this right now
well the last move is a surprise
um actually I mean I I love as you know
pushing the H Pawn and uh
um normally though you prepare this move
first by uh by defending that square he
might still be winning but he's made it
difficult for himself keeping the Rooks
on maybe uh just slightly more practical
and okay it's one porn versus oh look at
the bar that's the thing you know when
manga's reacts has he blundered the win
he thinks he's blundered the wind he
absolutely has because now that white
porn will just run and it can run for a
long time don't run with the one drop
your Bishop back attack Black's
remaining Pawn if the two pawns get
traded off there we go it's a simple
draw White's King coming up and Rook
against Bishop is a draw the Rick
defends the Knight it's a very English
about countdown momentum going before
it's too late oh whoa
happened Something's Happened
um it did feel a bit wrong for Magnus to
play this move I actually thought Magnus
had something a bit stronger but what is
in the air we haven't figured it out
Rook takes C7 is a threat in Queen d8
it's a blunder Without Really pausing
for thought without looking for the
opponent's moves without calculating oh
he just wants to hide Magnus Carlsen he
hates the way he made that blunder
Knight just needs to find a safe square
and this one will be game over
okay a few more checks from
Magnus he's just he just blunted his
Knight no way uh he just thought he was
threatening Checkmate in the corner of
the board but the White Queen now
defends against any checks and look at
his face he's still laughing there he's
had enough now has he had enough is he
resigning he's resigned okay there comes
a handshake oh he polite handshake
towards the black king but prag he
doesn't care he's cold as ice
I think the white knight and now the
White Knight getting booted around
oh from Gary this is a really risky move
the White Queen defending her Knight
can the bishop come and I think he
blunters a piece yeah yeah I mean Bishop
comes to to four because that was called
yeah this time of day I'm not sure he
finds the best move we see the stockfish
moves Bishop to E4 and stockfish says
wins a piece double attack simply
winning a piece now and Anish giri needs
back he's simply blundered that white
Knight's getting kicked away look at
Duda leaning back he knows he's in
trouble the pawns are rolling
the bars going all over the shop
this is Blitz chest through and through
anything possible and at the moment
white hanging on it dropped his Bishop
he just left his Bishop on priest a free
piece for Duda and this one is going to
be decided Magnus blundering again
Duda takes it he holds his nerve okay
here comes the Rook but where's it going
uh Liam Lee looking big favor at the
moment what's happening with the
it looks like he had a couple of seconds
left with just a small delay there but
uh oh dude in big trouble about to get
checkmated dizzy and now there's going
to be a fork Ah that's the end I think
four or four Duda
and look at report that is really
sadistic just stopping the white king
from move well okay it's only got one
square now um the white Bishop can't
move the white Rook can't move
or no he's gonna go for checkmate ah
he's coming in yeah
and uh I guess the plan would be
just to walk the king rugby three that's
nice and now they're masks C3 discovered
check yes that's it Checkmate next move
once the white king goes into the corner
the Rapport takes the win and he says no
it drawed not good enough for white and
white king running this one is
just blitzing out the moves fantastic
[Music]
it was Checkmate first time wow and that
means the niche giri loses and the
players were seconds left on the clock
oh this is so difficult
no way
no way Craig just blundered into
Checkmate in one move he was winning
to move
unbelievable he trapped his own King he
was winning that so easily Checkmate in
one he fell for a mate in one